- [groans]
OH, MY GOD.
- [yelps]
- LOUD.
LOUD!
- OFF.
- SHUT UP, GOSLING,
YOU BEAUTIFUL IDIOT.
- NICE SHOT, WENDELLS.
- I'M THE MICHAEL JORDAN
OF THROWING VICODIN EVERYWHERE.
- I'M SO HUNG OVER--SUELA,
CONSUELA, SUELA!
- OH, YAYO.
YAYO.
- WHY IS OUR LIFE SO [bleep]
HARD, WENDY?
- SHUT UP!
- YOU KNOW, I'M JUST GONNA HAVE
A LITTLE COFFEE.
[snorts and moans]
- I JUST GOTTA CHECK
MY EMAIL REAL QUICK.
- OH, GOD. OH, GOD.
[farts]
- OH, [bleep].
OH--
[farts]
- WHAT? WENDELLS, WHAT?
- [groans]
OH, GOD.
- I'M GOING AS FAST
AS I CAN, WENDELLS.
- OH, MY GOD, PLEASE HURRY.
I'VE GOTTA PUSH OUT
A BIG GRAY COKE SNAKE.
- OH, MY GOD,
I AM JUST SPRAYING
CHOCOLATE SHAVING CREAM
RIGHT NOW.
- YEAH. NO DURR.
- WHERE ARE THE BABY WIPES?
- I DON'T KNOW!
- FINE, I'LL JUST KEEP USING
THESE CARPET SAMPLES,
BUT WE NEED TO GO TO ONE
OF THOSE BIG BULK STORES
AND BUY, LIKE,
A THOUSAND ROLLS OF TP
AND WE'LL NEVER HAVE
TO GO TO A STORE AGAIN.
- THOSE BIG BOX STORES ARE
RUINING AMERICA.
- WE DO IT ONCE,
WE DO IT RIGHT.
WE'LL JUST GET
SHNEEFED TO THE DOME
AND THEN WE'LL GO MAKE FUN OF
FAT AMERICANS.
- OH, NICE.
- YEAH.
- I'M GONNA GO IN THE HOT TUB.
[groaning and splattering]
- WENDY, THAT'S NOT THE BIDET.
- WHAT?
- THAT'S NOT THE HUGE BIDET.